[Music]
let's turn now to professor robert
dingle he's a sociologist at nottingham
trent university
he does a thing or two about how you
respond to pandemics
he's advised the government on pandemic
response for many years
he sits on nerve tag it's the government
advisory group on new and emerging
respiratory virus threats he's appearing
today in a personal capacity
uh we're delighted to welcome him to
spectator tv
professor dingle is the government not
right
to be a bit cautious uh
about coming out of lockdown so that we
don't end up back in it
or we don't meet the unknowns what's
your overall view of the strategy
well i find it rather puzzling that the
the government has spent a great deal of
money on purchasing vaccines
rolling vaccines out that we have very
clear evidence from the clinical trials
and from the experience so far and from
the published work from israel
about how extraordinarily successful
vaccines are at
reducing deaths reducing hospital
hospitalizations
and generally transitioning
[Music]
the infection to somewhere comparable
with the other 30 or so respiratory
viruses that have
afflicted humanity since since forever
and yet we don't quite believe it um
you know the data there the data are
baked in the improvements
uh are rapidly coming through the system
and yet we have this continual
insistence on well
things might go wrong we should be doing
this just in case
you know we cannot possibly be too
cautious
without really taking account of all the
collateral damage that's being done
i mean your slides just there pointed to
the excess deaths from
cancer heart disease other conditions
they pointed to the economic damage
there's all the damage that's been done
to children and their education
you know we should really be attempting
to move as fast as is reasonably
practicable
rather than thinking well we must drag
everything out
until the very last person who wishes to
be vaccinated has been vaccinated
and has had another two or three weeks
to acquire immunity
and another three or four weeks until
we've crunched all the data
do you uh have a view then on on where
the government could move more quickly
out of locked lockdown and move more
quickly
towards at least a semblance of
normality what should it be doing
in your uh personal view that it's not
doing at the moment
well i think we could be moving much
faster once the
first phase of the vaccination program
is completed
somewhere around in the second half of
april by that time we've taken out
98 percent of the mortality risk almost
as much of the
severe illness risk there's a little bit
more in the
under 50 in the fort over 40s the 40 to
50 year olds
but i mean that could be marked up
fairly quickly
so we're then saying well why would we
lock up a low-risk
population for the summer rather than
thinking about
the maximum number of restrictions that
we can remove
early in may you might say well it's
only
six or eight weeks coming forward but
those six or eight weeks
are going to make a great difference to
the economy they're going to be
an opportunity for the health service to
get going on the
catching up with the backlog of elective
surgery at a time when
business is getting quieter there's a
chance for the
overstressed staff of the health service
to you know get a little bit of space to
relax and recover
and i really don't see the justification
for
postponing everything in way
way into the summer when
there is obviously one run small risks
but there are tolerable risks of
moving much more quickly so what did you
make of the sage
warning the famous sage advisory body to
the government with neil ferguson
probably the most famous member of it on
that saying this week that if you ease
too much before easter it could lead to
55 000 more deaths they projected
what do you say when you see something
like that well i think it's very hard to
see where these numbers are coming from
it the problem with models is always
that they're only as good as the data
that you put into them
and the assumptions you make to you to
join that data up
and the the modeling that we've seen so
far
it's made unrealistic assumptions about
the uptake of the vaccination and the
effectiveness of the vaccination
and the models haven't really been
corrected to
to allow for that it's made unrealistic
assumptions about fatality rates
which have been falling with the
improvements in treatment since
since last year and
you can play with the numbers you can
produce a reasonable worse case
but we tend not to hear what's the
reasonable best case
and since we're heading down towards you
know maybe a hundred deaths a day from
covid within the the next couple of
weeks
it's very hard to see where all those
excess deaths are going to come from
do you see any sign in the government's
announcements and in its deliberations
that
it could take this view that it it
begins down the
the path that it has already explained
but it said it looks and says hey this
is actually going better than we thought
um we could speed this up a bit is there
any chance that could happen
well i think there are certain
opportunities for that i mean if the
you know if the lines on the graph
continue in the same direction for
another two or three weeks
i would imagine that some conservative
mps will be asking very serious
questions about
whether they should vote for the renewal
of some of the powers at the end of
march
and i but i think the position is quite
clear that
the government will only move faster if
there are people pushing them to do so
um and the people pushing them to do so
will be pushing against some very
formidable obstacles
uh in terms of you know the risk
aversion of some ministers the risk
aversion some scientists
um and i i think this sort of
sense that you know the political elite
the scientifically the countries they
lead
have really been very comfortable you
know we could all work from home
you know we've got big houses and we've
got gardens and we're really
disconnected from the lives of the
the people who are serving us the people
who are doing the deliveries
working in the shops working the food
processing plants
um and you know they deserve to have
their lives thought about too
and what it would take for you know for
them to be
released from the the sort of
confinement that that we've
we've imposed over the last year or so
it's certainly true that those coming up
with the confinement
and not those who bear the brunt of that
confirmed confinement i think that's
true in the political and the scientific
elite and the media
elite as well they're they're all not
bearing the brunt of it
my guess would be that the prime
minister's instincts would be
to listen to you rather than to other
experts
but he's overwhelmed overcome
by what i would call the precautionary
principle that as a politician
is better he is over cautious
than takes what might be seen as a bit
of a gamble with
the kind of advice you would give well i
think it's one of the interesting things
andrew is that that phrase precautionary
principle has been used so incorrectly
all the way through
i mean when it was originally coined in
the 1990s
i i was doing work on this in connection
with genetically modified crops
the precautionary principle says
basically you don't do
stuff unless you've got a very thorough
appraisal
of the potential harms as well as the
potential benefits
and all the way through we've really
failed to give as much attention to the
harms of policies
as we have to the uh alleged benefits
so we've never really had this this sort
of balanced
look at what is happening to society
to the economy to the mental health of
the people
as a result of the various control
measures
now in part that's because the whole
sage network was set up
with a single issue focus you know
stop covid and you the
people involved with it are not asked to
consider the wider impact of their
actions
and i think that that has skewed the
advice coming to government
it's meant that there's been perhaps
less open debate
than there should have been within the
scientific community as much as within
the political community
and that the result of that is this sort
of drift
towards you know
if the objective is curbing covered at
all costs
then in a sense all costs become
justified
and what people like me i suppose are
trained to do
as sociologists is to put covid
into a context to say that there's a
societal pandemic here as well as a
biomedical pandemic
and that societal pandemic looks a bit
different and it
should point us towards a rather
different approach to the policies
which is which which has a more perhaps
a better balance between the intended
and the unintended consequences
so it's what we in economics would call
a full cost benefit analysis
of the whole policy professor we'll
leave it there i know you've got to get
away you have a busy
day uh we thank you for putting your
your case so coherently
and giving our viewers something to
think about different from
what they're hearing from government
professor ding well there thank you for
being
on spectator tv
[Music]
you